oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sur le
plateau de la grande interview une
grande interview réalisée bien sûr dans
les conditions sanitaires pour respecter
la distanciation social à l'abri donc
des risques dus qu'aux vide 19 notre
invité cette semaine philippe
douste-blazy
bonjour philippe douste-blazy alors je
ne vais pas revenir sur votre parcours
parce que tout le monde le connaît vous
êtes médecin cardiologue professeur de
médecine mais vous êtes tombé dans la
politique assez tôt 1 puisque vous avez
été maire de lourdes et puis maire de
toulouse mais vous avez surtout fait une
carrière au gouvernement sous le mandat
de jacques chirac la santé la culture
les affaires étrangères ait pu vous êtes
sortis de la politique des radars de la
politique pour revenir à votre vrai
métier
aujourd'hui deux médecins deux
cardiologues on vous a beaucoup entendu
lors du premier confinement parce que
vous ne pouviez pas ne pas vous exprimer
vous étiez souvent à parler à de
l'hôpital de garches où vous êtes fils y
est alors c'est ce parcours qui vous
donne une légitimité philippe
douste-blazy bas pour parler de la
situation actuelle 2e confinement
situation sanitaire d'abord et puis
réponses politiques administratives
ensuite tout cela vient de donner
d'ailleurs un livre que je recommande
ces maladies française aux éditions de
l'archipel
c'est un livre de colère de colère
contre le gouvernement contre le système
vous êtes en colère philippe
douste-blazy alors c'est un livre de de
colère en général pas spécialement
contre ce gouvernement
en fait si vous voulez en 2004 lorsque
j'étais ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé sous l'autorité du président
chirac
nous avons été les premiers en france à
établir définir de manière très concrète
le premier plan de contre une pandémie
virale
parce que la dernière était 1919 avec
plus de 50 millions de morts parce qu'on
savait très bien que un siècle après à
peu près il y aurait une nouvelle
épidémie est que nous n'étions pas prêts
et donc tout était prévu c'est à dire
que j'en savais que si le virus venait
de tels endroits ont fermé les
frontières ont réquisitionné les
industries textiles pour faire des
masques et c'est bien l'administration
française qui a été la première au monde
à savoir faire un plan comme celui-là a
été la première au monde aussi à
l'ignorer dans les années 2013 2014 2015
des commissions d enquête parlementaire
lui tirons pour que point que nous
n'étions pas menés en janvier février
2020 alors filez vous avez beaucoup
fréquenté les plateaux de télévision
notamment pendant le premier confinement
vous êtes un des médecins qui avaient
critiqué le plus sévèrement le
gouvernement dénonçant les erreurs et en
disant que finalement le remède qu'il
avait utilisé pour se protéger de ce
virus était peut-être pire que le mal
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième confinement vous
réagissez comment est ce qu'on pouvait
faire autrement finalement oui bien sur
terre que pour ceux qui nous écoutent
en fait c'est très très simple vous
l'avez vu tous les scientifiques tous
les médecins ne sont d'accord sur rien
pratiquement sur cette maladie qui est
nouvelle après tout essayé mais ce n'est
pas anormal non plus d'avoir plusieurs
visions de la ddt du traitement et de la
de la lutte contre cette maladie par
contre il ya une chose sur laquelle tout
le monde est d'accord
ils m'ont fait que plus vous dépister
massivement les gens au début dès qu'ils
ont les premiers petits signes et s'ils
veulent se faire dépister voulait
dépistés en 24 heures et moins
la mortalité est hot c'est à dire plus
vous dépister - les gens meurent et ça a
été vu en allemagne quatre fois moins de
morts qu'en france ça a été vu en
autriche 4 fois moins de morts qu'en
france a été vu en corée du sud etc
et donc pourquoi nous n'avons pas
dépister massivement et c'est ça le
sujet dans cette dans ce livre maladie
française
j'explique aux fonds que dans ce
ministère de la santé il a été décidé au
départ
que uniquement les machines qui devait
dépister étaient des machines uniquement
limitée au centre universitaire et on a
laissé comme ça de côté tous les
laboratoires d'analysés privé toutes les
cliniques privées
tous les laboratoires vétérinaires
toutes les centres de recherche parce
que nous sommes un des pays au monde à
avoir le plus de machines pcr par tête
d'habitant
nous ne les avons pas utilisé ouais
alors c'est assez c'est assez étonnant
face et même invraisemblable ce que vous
dénoncez là ça veut dire que
l'administration a pris le pouvoir et a
tout bloqué c'est à dire que au fond si
vous qui êtes un observateur de la vie
politique depuis longtemps aussi comme
moins au fond tout s'est passé au moment
du sang contaminé
de plus l'histoire du sang contaminé
tout fonctionnaire du ministère des
affaires sociales de la santé que par
ailleurs je respecte mais si vous voulez
iso une circulaire la circulaire
ministérielle dit il y as uniquement ces
machines qui sont référencés alors moi
j'ouvre le parapluie et je laisse
uniquement ces machines fonctionner et
les autres jeux de mots n'occupe pas
al'inverse en allemagne où le système
est beaucoup plus décentralisée et bien
le professeur droz dunk l équivalent du
professeur raoul tu as en allemagne et
bien a dit écoutez voilà tous les
laboratoires d'analysés qu'ils soient
publics qu'ils soient privés n'importe
où vous pouvez faire le test
et comme d'admistration du ministre de
la santé décentralisée dans les landes
heures et bien immédiatement tout le
monde l'a fait ben oui c'est cette hyper
administration cette hyper
centralisation que nous avons qui a été
extrêmement néfaste pourquoi je le dis
parce que les choses vont recommencer
c'est à dire que si on refait pareil
maintenant sélection de des pistes passé
ne profite pas de deuxième confinement
pour dépister systématiquement tous les
gens qui sont à risque ou même pour
casser les clusters casser les chaînes
de contamination et bien il y aura une
troisième vague au printemps et un
troisième confinement et ce pays sera
évidemment cloués au sol
alors on va revenir
mais auparavant une toute petite
parenthèse mais vous dit très justement
que le comportement de l'administration
est d'ailleurs de la classe politique
elle est fortement impactée par ce qui
s'était passé au moment du sang
contaminé et je crois que vous avez
mille fois raison on a peur du juridique
on a peur des tribunaux donc on se cache
mais je sens vous taquinez vous avez
quand même participer à un gouvernement
qui a inscrit dans la constitution le
principe de précaution et à l'époque je
n'ai pas souvenir que vous vous soyez
opposé à 7 à cette opération
mais vous avez tout à fait raison de le
dire parce que à l'époque que cette zone
de précaution ce avait été poussé par il
faut voir le contexte dans lequel
s'était c'était nicolas hulot qui avait
convaincu le président chirac de le
mettre dans la constitution pour
l'environnement et c'est vrai que à la
sortie au fond ces syndromes de
précaution j'appelle ça s appelle ça le
syndrome de précaution aujourd'hui
devient beaucoup trop important et en
tout cas tout le monde a peur de la
responsabilité pénale et on revient
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qu' il y a des
gens qui ont porté plainte on voit bien
que le premier ministre de l'époque
edouard philippe va avoir les mêmes
soucis que le premier ministre de
l'époque pendant le sont contaminés de
rumba bus et là il faut faire très
attention parce que nous devons avoir
des hommes politiques responsables ils
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités
on doit évidemment au change et qu'on
n'est pas contents d'eux mais si tous
les fonctionnaires de ce pays ont peur
d'aller en prison un jour parce que ils
sortent la circulaire alors qu'ils sont
persuadés qu'il faut sortir de la
circulaire là je pense que c'est très
mauvais c'est un premier sujet le
deuxième sujet c'est que malheureusement
nous n'avons pas eu des tables de chef
d'état major dans une guerre il faut un
chef d'état major
bien sûr il faut le président qui va
prendre ses responsabilités politiques
mais il faut aussi un chef d'état major
or la caisse convoi envoie un conseil
scientifique
une haute autorité pour la santé
le l'agencé du médicament l'académie de
médecine à la sortie si vous voulez tout
ça évidemment parlant sur les plateaux
de télévision à une formation continue
ou dans les radios et donc à la sortie
mais évidemment il y à une sorte de
l'embrouillamini des plus personne ne
sait qui fait quoi oui il faut un chef
d'état major qui soit pas uniquement
d'ailleurs rivés sur le ministère de la
santé mais aussi sur l'intérieur et la
défense parce que les fonctionnaires du
ministère de l'intérieur et les
ministères des formes d du ministère de
la défense sont des fonctionnaires qui
savent ce que c'est qu'une crise
beaucoup plus que des fonctionnaires du
ministère des affaires sociales
ouais alors philippe douste-blazy je
pense qu'on fera les comptes plus tard
au niveau des erreurs politiques
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
d'essayer de voir si ce que nous faisons
est utile et efficace et notamment
j'aurais voulu savoir ce que comment
vous situez dans ce débat qui
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils
finalement veulent protéger la vie à
tout prix et ceux qui voudraient
protéger l'économie parce que à moyen et
à long terme
on court à la ruine michel benchetrit
résonne au fond prenez l'exemple de nos
voisins allemands comme ils ont dépisté
tout de suite comme d'ailleurs didier
raoul tu l'as fait à marseille on se
moquait de lui parce qu'il y avait des
queues devant les hacher méditerranée
dans je suis d'ailleurs pourrait tout à
fait clair manque du côté scientifique
mais c'est pas pour ça que je creuse si
jamais il faisait une erreur je veux
dire est aussi très bon il y avait des
queues à l'époque tout le monde se
moquait de lui résultat à marseille tout
le monde prêter que mon qui voulait être
testée a été testé et a eu les résultats
surtout avec quatre heures résultat on a
isolé des malades et donc il est plus
contagieux la surmortalité à marseille
n'existe pas c'est à dire que en 2020 en
janvier février mars avril mai juin
juillet il n'y aura plus il y aura pas
eu plus de morts qu'en 2019 2018 2017
anne allemagne c'est la même chose ils
ont fait immédiatement des tests de
dépistage
résultat ils ont fait un confinement
léger ils ont malheureusement avec
google on sait aujourd'hui google
mobilité on sait qui bouge et qui ne
bouge pas et bien les allemands ont
continué pendant ce premier confinement
à faire des constructions le btp les des
travaux publics les bâtiments et travaux
publics continue et des magasins
continuent à fonctionner et c est donc
ils ont été beaucoup moins touchés
impact et économiquement c'est ma
réponse à votre question
si vous dépister tout de suite si vous
isoler les malades tout de suite
alors bien évidemment vous vous pouvez
éviter le confinement strict et la
catastrophe économique
donc la catastrophe économique elle ne
vient que ce groupe berneau à la
stratégie sanitaire alors ceci étant
mais si vous me le permettez je reprends
ma casquette d'économistes parce que
c'était mon métier
cette crise ne ressemble ni à une guerre
ni à un tremblement de terre les actifs
de production n'ont pas été détruits les
contrats de travail ont même été
préservés donc de ce point de vue le
gouvernement a fait quand même un
travail de prévention et on s'aperçoit
qu'à la fin même du confinement et bien
l'activité économique a rebondi de façon
assez spectaculaire
donc je dire que il faut relativiser
l'angoissent que l'on peut distiller
avec avec les risques économiques
est ce que est ce que vous ne vous êtes
pas là en train d'ajouter un peu de
l'anxiété à l'anxiété nous parce que je
pense que je l'écris dans ce livre
maladie française le gouvernement a bien
réagi sur le plan économique et je pense
que il y a eu je dirais là le choix de
garder comme vous l'avez très bien dit
l'appareil productif a été le bon choix
mais c'est sur le plan de la stratégie
sanitaire ou qu'est-ce qu'on paie
aujourd'hui on paie tout simplement le
fait et ça ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'économie que au mois de juillet au
mois d'août lorsque vous avez envie de
vous faire tester moi c'est arrivé avec
quelqu'un de ma famille qui voulait se
faire tester le 15 juillet à hossegor
dans les landes
eh bien j'ai
attendu nous avons attendu trois jours
pour avoir le rendez vous pour cet
examen est ensuite encore trois jours
pour avoir le résultat est bien c'est ce
que nous payons aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça que l'on à quatre fois plus de
contamination aujourd'hui en france qu
il n existe en allemagne ou en autriche
parce que on n'a pas testé dans on va
pas si vous voulez en permanence pleurer
sur le lait répandu
maintenant il faut savoir comment on
sort de là comment on peut dire aux
petites entreprises
comment on peut dire aux commerçants
écoutez dans deux mois c'est fini c'est
terminé vous allez réouvrir et on va
éradiquer cette maladie il faut pas être
dans une sorte d'ambiance on va diminuer
on va essayer de diminuer la
contamination non il faut les casser il
faut éradiquer la maladie est la seule
solution pour éradiquer la maladie il
faut faire ce que la nouvelle zélande
vient de faire alors je dis bien qu'à
n'a que 5 millions d'habitants mais ça
dd 1er mars contrôle de toutes les
frontières
15 mar fermeture des frontières famars
confinement strict comme celui qu'on a
connu et et dépistage de toute la
population et isolement de tous les cas
positifs
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un cas de co
vide ou deux peut-être sur 5 millions
d'habitants
un nouvelle zélande et bien c'est ça que
nous devons faire
philippe douste-blazy on revient dans un
quart de seconde sur ce point là parce
que c'est ce point là qui inquiète et
qui intéresse la population aujourd'hui
[Musique]
aller retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview où l'on retrouve philippe
douste blazy qui est en duplex à partir
de 2 chez lui comme tenu des problèmes
sanitaires dont on parle évidemment et
on lui parle beaucoup dans dans un livre
qui vient de sortir à l'archipel qui
s'appelle la maladie française et dans
lequel philippe douste-blazy vous
dresser un tableau assez sévère de la
gouvernance française au cours des des
dix ou quinze dernières années et vous
dénoncer les erreurs est faite
aujourd'hui par ce gouvernement on
aurait pu faire autrement dit vous mais
le temps n'est peut-être pas de juger et
de et de faire les comptes
je pense que la classe politique ne le
fera plus tard aujourd'hui alors que
nous sommes en pleine deuxième vague
avec des taux de pandémie qui sont
importants qui sont même assez
gravissime
vous dites vous il faut absolument
casser la circulation du virus
il faut absolument tester mais à partir
du moment où en avons nous n'avons pas
ces tests où nous n'avons pas les
équipements pour ça
comment fait-on alors nous avons les
équipements et nous pouvons avoir les
équipements au monde n'est pas possible
d'être cinquième ou la sixième puissance
économique du monde et de ne pas avoir
les meilleures machines au monde ça
c'est absolument impossible c'est quand
même de volonté alors il ya plusieurs
choses
aujourd'hui au moment où nous parlons
nous savons très bien que le grand
risque c'est que vers le 20 novembre il
y ait entre 8000 et 9000 personnes
atteintes de co vide en salle de
réanimation ça serait une double
catastrophe d'abord une catastrophe
parce que leurs pronostics de vie
seraient en jeu et ensuite parce que
tous ceux qui vont normalement
réanimation ne pourrait pas y aller il y
a aujourd'hui la remise fond il y a des
gens qui ont des cancers un ami qui est
urologue qui avait cancer du de la
prostate ou des cancers
de la vessie et bien il choisit
actuellement de taux opérées plutôt les
cancers de la vessie
parce que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
agressif et beaucoup plus grave qu'un
cancer de la prostate ma femme
personnellement j'aurai un cancer de la
prostate on me demanderait d'attendre
pendant deux mois ou trois mois je serai
catastrophé au fond parce que je
perdrais des chances de survie donc
aujourd'hui oui oui oui il faut bien
évidemment faire le plus possible
attention mais qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est le fameux air lorsque le r c'est à
dire je suis contaminé je vais contaminé
une virgule quatre personnes c'est ce
qui s'est passé le premier jour du
contenu du deuxième confinement je
rappelle qu'au premier confinement
c'était trois et demi d'eau glacée 1,4
donc on va baisser ce taux grâce au
confinement si il est bien fait on va le
passer à 0,7
et c'est ce jour là au moment où on sera
à 07 c'est à dire qu'on ne sera pas
cinquante mille personnes par jour qui
seront contaminés mais uniquement sa
guise le jour
monsieur sylvestre où on sera à 5 min
par jour
c'est là là où il va falloir mettre des
millions et des millions de tests
rapides à la disposition des français
alors on me dit que y en a pas mais
pourquoi alors à marseille aujourd'hui à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
marseille alliée à celle de marseillan
vous donne le résultat pcr je parle pas
des tests antigénique pcr on vous les
donne en 20 minutes donc je pense que
c'est ça c'est la stratégie une
stratégie extrêmement rigoureuse qu'il
faut mettre en place dès l'instant où le
taux a baissé
sinon on ne donnera pas de perspectives
aux français non on va pas leur dire en
permanence fermée ceux ci n'allait pas
là n'allait pas au restaurant je vous
assure que si on fait ça on pourrait
ouvrir très rapidement tous les magasins
les resteront les cinémas et librairies
donc donc en test et on met en
confinement
les gens qui sont positifs
on est bien d'accord mais ça bien sûr
alors on le teste et bien évidemment
ceux qui sont positifs doivent être
isolées j'ai ce système qui ne marche
pas suffisamment haut sont aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui n'a pas
shawn et c'est que dès l'instant où vous
avez plus de 5000 ou des 1000 cas par
jour c'est fini c'est incontrôlable
parce que si je suis contaminé
aujourd'hui et si je ne sais pas
pourquoi et qui me l'a donné c'est fini
donc les chaînes de contamination ça ne
fonctionne que si on sait de savières or
nous avons mis en place des systèmes en
france qui est un système au téléphone
fait par des fonctionnaires de
l'assurance maladie et je les respecte
ce sont des gens qui ont très bien
travaillé mais bon il faut un médecin il
faut des infirmières
il faut des personnes qui connaissent ce
métier moi je suis médecin
je sais que quand je parle à quelqu'un
je sais qu'à un moment donné la
confiance va se mettre en place et donc
si je vais lui demande il lui demande
combien de personnes avez vous vu depuis
10 jours on va regarder ça ensemble
ce n'est que pour moi personne ne le
saura on va on va travailler en
confiance
ensemble et ensuite je vais téléphoner à
ces personnes résultat au début du
système les gens disaient qu'ils avaient
vu quatre à cinq personnes en dix jours
et à l'acheteur du système parce qu'il
n'avait pas confiance
il disait qu'il veut plus pratiquement
personne une personne et demi ou deux
personnes c'est ça qui nous a fait
perdre de la guerre mais mais mais
méfiant blazy quand on écoute les
médecins il vise deux populations en
général ils visent la population des
jeunes des ados et des étudiants qui
aurait fait la fête et qui seraient des
agents asymptomatiques propagateur du
virus
et puis d'un autre côté il parle des
personnes seniors ou des personnes à
risque qui eux ont besoin d'un
traitement et ont besoin de réanimation
on ne pourrait pas dans ce pays nous
dit-on isoler ces deux catégories là et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on fait un
confinement général
vrai ou faux alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que la moyenne
l'âge moyen des personnes qui décèdent
du coc vide et de 84 ans ce qui est vrai
c'est que 70 % des personnes qui sont en
réanimation sont en surcharge pondérale
ce qui est vrai c'est que 50% des
personnes en réanimation ont de
l'hypertension artérielle très élevé et
enfin ce qui est vrai c'est que 28 % de
ces gens là ont un diabète
donc vous voyez c'est à la fois des
personnes
au fond les personnes qui meurent sont
des personnes qui sont très âgés mais ce
qui est vrai aussi c'est qu'on voit dans
cette deuxième vague qu'il ya aussi des
gens de 40 ans de 50 ans qui sont en
réanimation dieu merci le tout deux
mortels a baissé de pratiquement 50% de
40 45 % depuis le début dire que entre
les premiers qui arrivait au début
février en réanimation et ce qui arrive
maintenant en réanimation y meurt
beaucoup moins pourquoi parce que nous
savons aujourd'hui qu'il fallait pas
tout il faut pas tous les incubés il
faut mettre 2 l'oxygène nous arrivons à
mettre maintenant de l'oxygène à 30
litres par minute des choses que l'on
faisait pas au début deuxièmement des
anticoagulants une maladie qu un train
des thromboses et enfin des corticoïdes
à forte dose donc c'est ça donc si vous
laisse y en avait si on avait une
stratégie aujourd'hui à faire la
stratégie elle serait à mon avis de
contrôle est extrêmement bien toutes les
frontières
beaucoup plus qu'on ne le fait
deuxièmement ce serait de faire le
confinement là mais dès l'instant où on
passe à cinq mille paroles par par jour
alors tester tester tester tout le monde
est isolé comme vous l'avez très bien
dit tout à l'heure les personnes positif
et enfin je pense qu'il faudrait
responsabiliser beaucoup les personnes à
risque soit parce qu'elles sont
diabétiques en surcharge pondérale ou
hypertension soit parce qu'elles ont
plus de 65 ans et cela il faut vraiment
leur dire de faire très attention y
compris en voyant beaucoup moins les
jeunes générationnel cdp nous reste très
peu de temps
j'ai deux questions la première
concerne le professeur didier rahout
vous êtes un proche du professeur didier
rahout il ad'ailleurs préfacé votre
livre maladie française là qui saura
actuellement j'ai bien lu sa préface
vous assumer tout ce qu'il a fait parce
qu'on a quand même aussi le sentiment
que cette publicité qui a été fait
autour de ces propos qui étaient parfois
très transgressif a plutôt perturbé le
jugement qu améliorer la situation
si vous voulez il ya deux choses les
gens confondent deux choses il ya la
personnalité de dédit raul qui est une
chose moi que je dirais que je ne
revienne pas ce n'est pas le sujet par
contre ce que je fais et ce que je fais
c'est à dire c'est incroyable puisque le
seul en france à avoir dépisté
massivement mais personne ne lui mais
enfin tout le monde lui rend hommage sur
ça il n'y a pas une personne qui peut
dire qu'il s'est trompé il
il est absolument incroyable de voir que
tous les gens qui veulent se faire
tester à marseille seul fonds d'ester
est ensuite immédiatement il y à une
mise à l'écart un isolement
et ça c'est formidable mais comme et
estreito ils voient les gens très
précocement comme ils voient les gens
très précocement ils sont dans la phase
virale et la m nandy virale personne ne
vous dira que c'est une erreur que ce
soit les drogues figurent au quine ou
autre chose et donc ce qu'il dit et des
résultats qu'il dit
il vient de sortir il ya quelques jours
une étude très intéressante en appui des
ehpad la moitié des ehpad ont été
traités par hydroxy croquer
l'azithromycine l'autre partie des ehpad
c'est en double aveugle sans rien et
bien la première 27 pour la première 13
% de mortalité
ce que vous été soigné par un des
premiers ciné de russie khl rocky 13 %
de mortalité
ceux qui n'ont pas été soignées pas ce
médicament 27 % hors 27 % c de moyenne
que l'on a trouvé en france
donc attention attention il faut pas
générer des gens qui sont contre raul
parce qu'il dit jeune amant le meilleur
je suis une star ça les énerve c'est
l'évêque
ça c'est une chose ouais je ne parle pas
de ce à quoi je parle que des résultats
oui non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya autant
d'ego dans les milieux mai
ico que dans les milieux politiques non
un dernier point très rapidement parce
que vous avez vécu huit ans aux états
unis après votre carrière politique
française vous étiez à l'onu à un mot
sur sur l'amérique qui sort d'une
élection complètement fracturée est-ce
que vous pensez que cette amérique là
peut se réconcilier quelque part je suis
frappé de voir que dans les démocraties
aujourd'hui envoie des populations
fracturée c'est aussi en partie un peu
chez nous dire les gens ne s'écoutent
plus et donc au fond la campagne
électorale joue pratiquement pour rien
parce que avant de faire changer entre
en piste d'avis ou quelqu'un pour baden
mais c'est très difficile on le voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais non
commencés en considérant les français et
considérant qu'elle les européens vous
savez que ce soit joe biden
où que ce soit trump il n'y aura pas de
différence dans la politique étrangère
que ce soit validé notre up
ils ne veulent pas que les chinois
prennent le dessus et près de vienne la
première puissance économique mondiale
ils continueront à ne pas aimer l'europe
l'union européenne et à nous mettre des
bâtons dans les roues est la seule
solution pour nous que ce soit
d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de la chine deux
des états unis nous devons avoir une
union politique avec une autonomie sur
la défense une autonomie sur la santé
cette crise sanitaire la montre et je
les big data est également bien sûr cela
5g way fait des pas du slbc l'asie merci
beaucoup on aurait pu encore continuer
cette émission est chargé pendant
beaucoup de minutes je rappelle votre
livre maladie française aux éditions de
l'archipel
jeudi au passage qu'on peut le commander
pas seulement sur e-commerce mais on
peut aussi le commander chez les
libraires parce que si les libraires ne
peuvent pas ouvrir et c'est un peu une
bizarrerie d'ailleurs du confinement que
nous vivons ils peuvent très bien livrer
des livres si on leur commande
vous retrouverez cette émission en
rediffusion sur l'antenne mais aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux
et puis sur le site internet rt france
point tv philippe douste blazy continuer
à vous battre continuer à travailler
merci encore à très vite
[Musique]